discipline cards
come on details conquered worlds wage
war across the galaxy to prove my
the swallows light
have merely forgotten the fear of
[Music]
allow me to reacquaint you
[Music]
the earliest cabal records that can be
found
talk about a mythical emperor called a
curious according to legend a curious
wanted to claim the Sun and once he was
successful in doing so he became the
first emperor of the Cabal a curious
ruled the Cabal Empire alongside the
military aristocracy known as the
Praetorian which much like a lot of
empires in history meant that the
majority of the population would suffer
while they pretoria leaders grew fat
with power and wealth according to
Kellis the preterite was corrupt and
parasitic the strength came from the
control of the Cabal legions who lacked
citizenship within the Empire and we
used to predict and conquer for the
preterite masters careless leader
populous revolution to remove the
Praetorian power and he was named
emperor of the Cabal empire after taking
power he immediately went to exceeding
the ProTour its vast accumulated wealth
her redistribution among the people and
granting citizenship to the Imperial
legions calles went on to poach the
rhetoric he and his Imperial Guard
rushed into the temple with a former
cabal Senate convened and assassinated
them but at the same time some were more
of a threatened death than if they keep
him alive calluses new government would
include some expert oriT and advocate
general human wrath worse it as the
Primus of all legions the golden days of
calluses rain so the Cabal empire
changed from not just a militaristic
warfare and civilization but an empire
of learning gentility willpower and
subtlety technological advancements were
made towards meeting every need and
previously with the welfare of the
people with solve the lowest concern
calles placed importance on insisting
that his people of a life of comfort as
the Cabal Empire expanded had
encountered countless alien races and
absorb them into itself the technology
knowledge and culture was merged into
the Empire the number of species in the
Cabal Empire was an all-time high and
the things that they created were
carefully archived for potential future
use towards the betterment of the people
but calluses rain wasn't without issues
boomin earth has appointed Primus of all
legions
was paranoid and showed an obsessive
fixation on war in the ways of the past
on top of this his own daughter and heir
title grew up with a similar mind frame
despite his best efforts calluses
greatest passion during this golden age
was the Coliseum where gladiators would
be pitted against each other in a test
of strength martial arts and combat
intelligence eventually a day came we're
a new gladiators stepped foot into the
ring one who was unlike the rest his
patience skill and unusual coloration
very quickly made him a favorite of
calluses and this gladiator was named go
over time the Emperor decided that goals
talents could be put to better use and
made him the Primus of the red Legion
although he was aware of cabal's
association with former members of the
protoid he wasn't concerned ball had
become like a son to Callas
he believed that lower kindred spirits
who both envisioned a more perfect world
and this was the oversight that would
eventually leave to the end of callouses
reign over the Kabala empire the console
was a scholar and aristocrat of the
preterite when the preterite was
overthrown by callus the console lost
all of his power and influence and was
personally castrated by callus to ensure
he would be a no ears at some point the
console stumbled across goal a young
orphan who'd been lifted did goal was
born a runt with albinism and was
abandoned at birth to die of exposure
which was according to cabal custom he
took all of the traveler and instilled
in him a belief that the gevalt deserved
his power by right goal knew how the
console was using him but accepted it as
a fair exchange for his upbringing goals
grown friendship with emperor Kellis led
to trust in favor being granted but
despite this Gauls loyalties remained
with the console he began plotting a
coup against the Emperor utilizing what
remained of the Praetorian and a number
of calluses closest allies and advisors
these included calluses own daughter
title Ivica general room and wrath and
calluses closest bodyguard with the
console in the red Legion who decide Gul
invaded the Emperor's Palace and
arrested Calais this was done during the
middle of a late night court celebration
with the assistance of callouses
daughter and personal bodyguard too
popular among the people to kill
outright Gaulle had Calais exiled to the
Leviathan the Emperor and his remaining
military supporters were marched into
the Leviathan sealed with an and
launched fire into space along a
pre-programmed course with Kellis gone
bull titled himself Dominus and declared
himself the leader of the new cabal
regime the console became his most
trusted advisor and lifelong friend Gaul
declared that there would be no more
Empress and that everyone could attain
greatness if they worked hard for it all
took no time in abolishing a number of
the idealisms that Calais put in place
the Cabal would once again become a
fully militarized conquering
expansionist empire award driven machine
under his leadership the bowel culture
moved from hedonism and pleasure for all
to militarism and personal glory the
Empire subtlety was replaced by brute
industrial force and at Concord species
rather than absorbing them into the
culture prior to the taken war the Cabal
were assembling a new force on Phobos
led by the sky bonus the goal to invade
earth however after the arrival of Oryx
in a streak naught the Cabal were forced
to evacuate their fleet base and other
sites in the system due to taken
infestations with the sky burners being
redeployed to reinforce other Cabal
forces during the taken war the campaign
against earth was temporarily placed on
hold during this time the commander of
the sky bonus Primus terrowin
sent a report to the Cabal High Command
saying that the hive technology on the
Dreadnought could be commandeered for
cabal use eventually his report reached
Dominus Gul who ordered her on to board
and capture the hive ship by any means
necessary
darn proceeded to ram his warship into
the dreadnought in order to establish a
beachhead on board
while leading a squad through the ship
terrowin was taken and transformed into
towel on hand of Oryx two of Torrance
most loyal officers the shield brothers
went forth to plant explosive said the
ship's Power Core to avenge their lost
premise the following explosion would
have destroyed half the solar system
fortunately a guardian fireteam was able
to step in and put a stop to the shield
brothers before the explosives could be
detonated two years after the taken war
the Cabal empires response would finally
arrive the red Legion under the command
of Dominus Gul would launch an attack
against the last city taking the city by
surprise the red Legion rapidly
overwhelmed to destroyed the tower while
at the same time a large machine was
sentient electrons to the traveler the
speaker would be kept alive his call was
intrigued by his connection to the
traveler after a series of battles
Guardians board at Gulf ship they
managed to destroy the shield generators
only to be confronted by Dominus call
himself as they stood face to face the
machine attached to the traveler
activated its shield
stripping all guardians of their light
after preaching a story like all good
films do Gore went ahead and beating the
guardians around a bit before literally
kicking them off his ship
Gul pushed the traveler to choose him
and join his empire while the Consul
advised him that it was just a machine
he wasn't to be reasoned with
the travelers should just be taken by
force Gould disagreed and hit the
speaker brought to him hoping to find a
way to talk to it
the remaining read Legion forces were
dispersed into the European dead zone to
hunt down guardians to nisus to study
the vex and to Mars to reinforce the
Cabal forces there for a time the red
Legion maintained complete control of
the solar system despite the loss of
they light the Vanguard leadership to
launch an attack to reclaim the last
city the console angrily demanded Gul to
take the light from the traveler to
destroy the Guardians the Dominus
however remained adamant then he needed
to prove his worth to be chosen by the
traveler
in his rage the console released the
weakened speaker and ranted that goal
had already been chosen not by the
traveler but by the console himself
angered by the consoles arrogant and
subordination Gaul killed his advisor
will eventually agreeing that the light
must be taken by force goal was to face
off against the Guardians once again
except this time he would be in control
of the light giving him similar
abilities to the Guardians however the
light he had was corrupted and after a
battle with the Guardians Gaul was
eventually defeated with their light
restored the Guardians succeeded in
reclaiming the city and driving the red
Legion away after the death of Gaul the
former emperor of cabal Calais arrived
in the solar system
I bought the Leviathan and immediately
set to work on reclaiming the Empire he
gave elements of the leaderless red
Legion the chance to join the loyalists
regime sending them on missions to
collect data on mrs. Calais extended an
invitation to the Guardian to board his
vessel for slaying Gaul accepting
callouses challenge the Guardians go on
to fight through his palace defeating
his loyalists army the Guardians met
Calais in person and his throne room and
after facing off against the former
emperor they managed to break him down
and defeat him except it turns out it
wasn't him it was a robot built in his
likeness Calais were not to talk about
how powerful he really was and that he
knew the real truth about the galaxy and
the traveler regardless he rewards the
Guardians for completing his challenge
and goes on to offer them a place by his
side if they were willing to take it
later on the guardians are once again
called upon to board the Leviathan this
time to fight off fix X's mate Argos the
Leviathan consumed a chunk of the planet
missus that contained the powerful Vic's
mind the guardians were successful and
destroying the intrusion in repairing
the ship but with Argos as she'll gone
the Guardians would then open themselves
up to being consumed by the fiery bowels
of the Leviathan caliph saves the
Guardians and once again offers them a
place by his side he also cryptically
warns and that the end is near and
therefore must be ready once again the
Leviathan would come under threat this
time from a resurgence of the red Legion
Valkyr I took advantage of the power
vacuum and quickly asserted himself as
the commander of the red Legion Valkyr
our leader fleet against the Leviathan
in order to kill the Emperor Calais and
seize the ship the guardians would once
more be called in to assist Calais would
watch over as Koror is killed by the
guardians and is impressed that they
have grown fat from strength and power
Calais tells the Guardians that he
awaits the day that they will stand by
his side when the end comes and this
brings us up-to-date with the update
coming later in the year which ought to
hear more about Emperor Calais and his
plans to further tease and taunt the
Guardians as well as further requests
for them to join us side to my Tom
Clancy viewers that have made it this
far don't worry I haven't stopped
covering this game some just simply
branching out testing the waters like a
number of games that have looked into in
the past I was just seeing if the
destiny story wouldn't treat me enough
to continue and I can certainly say that
after the hours and days of research
that yes the Destiny universe doesn't
just interest me but it's extremely deep
and story I know these videos aren't
likely to get much in the way of views
but I've thoroughly enjoyed putting them
together and I look forward to
researching more before I go anyone
who's been following me for a while will
be aware of how bad I am at pronouncing
names and the distance well they're just
Nick's level and difficulty so for those
of you who would like to poke fun at my
pronunciation or even just my Kiwi
accent in general please leave a comment
below the best one I come across will be
pinned as the top comment otherwise
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one Cheers
to this suffering one way
or another
[Music]